Uh,
the first one I say,
from my understanding,
the essential problems with epistemology
derive from the nature of language and
axioms upon which various underlying
linguistic structures are based.
And then afterwards interpreted,
as you have said in your videos,
the probability that you construe some
of the same definitions of insert random
word,
person says,
and in the same way are virtually zero,
or one of the best examples I can give
for this is the language that is used in
physics.
It is widely misconstrued as the
pragmatic meanings behind words and
their contexts are worlds debased from
the vague linguistic constructed views
of the actual linguistic,
uh,
definitions that people construe so,
such as the problem with the word
dimension,
dimension in which it is understood in
the semantic sense,
but not in an abstract sense in which
the word is implied.
The first chapter of Einstein's theory
of special and general relativity,
Einstein stresses that geometry is an
abstract model.
Time per se is not the dimension.
The theory of special relativity merely
treats any one clock time as dimension
of an abstract construct.
So for the next three questions I have,
I want this to be considered as a means
of,
okay,
so,
so my answer to that,
fundamentally I think the best answer to
that was provided by the American
pragmatists and that'd be William James
and his crew.
That would include guiding her pierce P
I e R,
c e m who was perhaps the,
you know,
the best floors for the American,
the US ever produced cns pierce,
but somewhat under appreciated and
certainly so in his own life.
Part of the way that different people
hone in on the same definition is to
define what an acceptable outcome would
be to their joint interactions and then
to hone their language until they
achieve that outcome.
And then to consider that good enough.
I would say pearson,
his crew basically said that you could
never do anything better than that.
So let's say that we're trying to.
Let's say we're trying to communicate
about how we're going to move a
wheelbarrow full of bricks from one side
of the yard to the other.
Well,
basically what we've decided is we've
communicated good enough if the bricks
get moved.
And so,
so what you have to do is you have to
set up a practical surround in some
sense around your conversation and the
practical surround constitutes what you
are willing to consider as proof that
conversation or that communication has
taken place sufficiently.
I mean that's partly,
it's complicated and it's partly why the
robotics engineers tried,
like Rodney Brooks were discovered back
in the 19 eighties that you really
couldn't have intelligent machines
without embodiment because you need a
real world target against which to
measure the effectiveness of your
communication.
Because as you said,
I mean this is where the postmodern is
to have it right,
is that there is a lot of different ways
of interpreting everything.
So how do you know when your
interpretation is good enough?
And the answer to that is you agree a
priority.
What would constitute good enough?
And when you hit that target,
then you're done.
Oh,
thank you.
And I'll look into CSPS.
Yep.
Cs Paris.
Yeah.
Look up the American pragmatists and go
to bright man.
Alright.
And then so,
and then the next one is on
transgenderism and conservative.
Strongly boast of biological and
scientific claim of two genders or two
sexes based on what language we're going
to use.
Um,
they believe and I believe,
right,
fully so in biological differences
between males and females,
but I've never heard a liberal argue and
from my perspective,
I think I could partially combat this,
but it's an argument that hasn't been
raised from the liberal side,
which I think should have,
um,
biological differences in the brain.
Women can see more shades of color on
average and men can have better spatial
orientation.
On average.
I'm Steven.
There's massive neurological and
biological differences between women are
well documented,
but the postmodernist types just assume
that the scientist who conducted the
investigations are suffering from the
same bias that they think permeates
everything else.
So they just discounted.
Yes.
So is it,
is it really crazy to believe that
someone could be born with biological
similarities to an x,
y,
brain and biological?
Excellent.
Not at all.
No.
That is the argument that I'm making.
The argument I'm making is that gender
identity is strongly influenced by
biological sex.
The problem is is that the legislation,
especially the legislation that's being
introduced in Canada,
argues that it's not.
That's just not helpful.
It's not even helpful for the
transgendered types because some of them
for sure,
there are people who have mixed
biological sex women who have some cells
in their body that have male
chromosomes,
trivial number for example,
and there are people who are born with
genitalia that are identifiable and
there are more genuine hermaphroditic
types and there is no different,
no doubt that there are some men that
have a more feminine personality
structure in some women that have a more
masculine personality structure and then
that's biologically influenced.
So I would separate.
I'm not making a biological case that
there are two genders that end.
Okay.
Thank you.
I'm making a biological.
I'm making a case that sexual identity
has been unbelievably powerfully
influenced by biology with certain
exceptions and those exceptions
themselves might be biologically
determined.
Not In all cases but in many.
And so part of the reason I was
objecting to legislation like bill
[inaudible] is because it insists that
gender identity is socially constructed
well.
If gender identity is socially
constructed,
then why can't we just take transgender
people and socialize them back into
their.
Into their normative sex roles?
Exactly.
Right.
So that's part of the reason I was
objecting to the legislation.
One of the most powerful arguments,
and I said this,
I did a presentation in front of the
Canadian Senate.
I don't know if you saw that or not.
There's no reason for you to have paid
attention to it,
but if you look up Jordan Peterson and
Senate,
you'll see that as well along with a
professor along with a practicing
lawyer.
I made exactly that case to a number of
Canadian senators telling them that by
supporting this legislation,
they were actually doing a disservice to
the people that they purport to be
helping.
So that's,
that's it,
isn't that biologically there are two
sexes,
although a pr as an approximation.
That's true.
As a decent approximation.
It's true.
It gets slightly messy because we're our
multiplicity of ways than sexuality and
sex differences manifest themselves and
those a fair bit of variability across
all of those different manifestations.
And so,
as I said,
you can have feminine man and a
Masculine Male,
masculine woman that happens very
frequently.
Um,
it's just more often you have a feminine
woman and a masculine man.
Alright,
that perfectly explains my question.
Okay.
So next postmodern is thought,
and I think you kind of already talked
about this,
um,
when you said the American postmodernist
got this right.
And that I'm going to summarize very
quickly because you've already answered,
but like,
um,
you say that you see scientific realism
is nested in Darwinian competition.
And so it's reasonably objective that
the,
oh no,
no,
that's not quite right.
I would say that it isn't obvious to me
that there is any truth that,
that is super ordinary to,
to the truth.
It's established in the Darwinian
fashion.
And that includes our notion of,
of objective reality.
Now that's where Sam Harris and I had a
major disagreement,
but again,
it has,
it's a consequence of,
of my pragmatic thinking.
You see the Darwinian claim
fundamentally is that the only way that
you can come up with a definition of
truth is throwing an evolutionary model
that uses death as the punishment being
wrong.
And so one of the things I was arguing
with with Sam Harris about is whether or
not our current conceptualizations of
objective truth are necessarily true in
a Darwinian sense,
and if they're not,
which form of truth should take
priority.
And I was arguing the Darwinian truth
should take priority and Sam was arguing
that,
well,
well he didn't particularly like that
stamps,
although one of the law.
And that's basically what our argument,
what argument circulated around.
So.
So the problem is,
see the problem is,
is that we never know.
Let's see,
what's the problem?
Exactly.
Even our objective truth is seriously
bounded in ways that we don't
understand.
Claim claim it as at any given moment as
having some sort of fundamental
ontological status outside of it's
Darwinian utility strikes me as
dangerous,
especially given how trans mutable
scientific theories tend to be.
So let's,
if I'm going to oversimplify things,
liberals tend to think with the anterior
cingulate cortex of the brain with
future applications,
possibilities,
likeliness consequences in conservative
part of the brain that's involved in
social cognition name and conservatives
tend to trust it.
So,
um,
yeah,
I'm going to read what I wrote here.
For example,
low populations in rural areas would
potentially possess more views of self
photometry,
working hard,
family values,
increasing population,
protecting oneself,
and one's kind due to the types of
motivations and the hypothalamus being
more applicable to survival while highly
populated areas would focus potentially
more on thinking tolerance,
community values,
stabilizing population,
but additionally might not focus so much
on protecting life or raising children.
These differences could explain vastly
the moral behaviors being ideally are
objectively true based on incalculable
variables.
So a better run.
Run that through me.
Again,
it's quite complicated.
Yes it is.
So I am suggesting that if we are to
look at a,
a reason why,
how people think,
we can look at how people think as being
nested in Darwinian competition.
So,
so if,
if there's a low populated area you
would think,
okay,
what traits incalculable,
but some somewhat telltale global trends
would be unnecessary for them to be
raised and what traits mostly in the
hypothalamus I'm assuming and what
traits would be more applicable for a
large city.
So it's almost completely possible that
the politics of liberals is perfect for
their situation in a big city,
in the politics of conservatives as.
Yeah,
this is one that you should think about.
It is,
it isn't.
It's a reasonable hypothesis.
I'd have to think it through a long time
before,
before because you're suggesting that a
conservative philosophy is more useful
in a.
yeah,
low populated area.
Possibly.
Yeah.
It's possible.
I think.
I don't know.
It's worth thinking.
All right.
That's because I've been thinking about
that a lot.
That's my main.
The main thing I think about,
um,
and I'm not saying necessarily directly
that,
but at least the possibility of.
That's why
one thing you could do just to,
to some degree to begin with is just run
a correlation between size of the
community and,
and uh,
and political proclivity you should go
get that data on the light online
wouldn't be approved because it might be
the more liberal types are also more
likely to move to the cities,
right?
In this case you'd be leading
conservatives be hard and it's not
because they're more well adopted by
even then it might be because they're
more well adapted into smaller
communities.
It's a good idea.
I don't know what think of it,
but it's worth thinking about.
Um,
and we actually have that data just
through political polls and you'll see
whenever you look at a map it's all red
because the red is in the smaller areas
and the blue looks small because it was
more people there.
So it does
tendon,
it's a plausible hypothesis.
It might be interesting to look in the
red states only and see if it's still
true there.
Yes.
Alright.
So thank you for that.
I mean it's,
let that you,
um,
think of that as a possibility.
And then one last question on religion,
and I've been watching your,
um,
your psychological interpretations of
the Bible as well as I have read the
maps of meaning.
Um,
so I may have missed something there.
but this question,
so neurophysiologically to my
understanding,
the way the human brain is constructed
is such that happiness is achieved in
the pursuit of a noble aim rather than
the team of the goal itself.
You've talked about this multiple times.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That,
it's not even,
it's not happiness precisely,
but that'll do.
It's more like a sense of meaningful
engagement,
which I think is better than happiness,
but that's okay.
We can go with happiness for now.
All right.
So if,
if there's no noble aim,
we are limited to simple pleasures which
do not sustain sustainable.
That's exactly right.
You're limited to impulsive pleasures.
Yes.
And those are ones that don't
necessarily have a good medium to
longterm outcome.
So if I am to take a psychological or
more of you or moral view of biblical
teaching,
like the scientific view,
um,
is,
am I right in construing that the idea
of external happiness without suffering
exists as a brilliantly thought out
construct which invokes a sense of
purpose and happiness.
And if I am to make that conclusion,
can I see those concepts in the moral
psychology of the Bible as manipulative
or does the defiance of natural law rule
out a literal interpretation?
Okay,
go back.
Read that again.
So if I,
if I'm to assume all of this with heaven
and hell,
and is it an eternal happiness is
that's.
Can you see that as manipulative as like
you can.
I mean certainly marks did.
I would say Freud did as well.
One of the problem,
because for the thought of a religion
as,
let's call it both manipulated the vim
and immature because it burned people
the certainty of life after death.
And it allowed them the comfort of
knowing that an all seeing father was
watching over them.
Okay.
And for,
I'd regard that,
let's say as immature and manipulative,
but he didn't have a good explanation
for why people came up with the idea of
hell because if you were just going to
go for immature and manipulative,
it might as well be all positive,
right?
Why put the negative in there?
And you could say skeptically,
well hell is where you put your enemies.
But that's a really cynical
interpretation because many religious
people and now certainly even,
but certainly throughout the Middle Ages
were terrified that hell was something
that they were headed to do.
Not the random is we're going to.
So I don't think that that's a
reasonable interpretation.
Historically.
I know mark's would say that the,
that religion was when do whatever it
could to manipulate people so that the
power structure is the economic power
structures can stay in place.
But um,
given that religion,
religious structures,
and this is,
I would say particularly but not only
true of Christianity,
have played a tremendous role in giving
additional voice to the people who are
downtrodden and slaved.
That that also was a historically
that's,
that's not a historic,
incredible argument.
Sometimes religious teachings are used
to buttress the people who are in
control and sometimes they're used to
oppose them.
So I don't mind that for a second.
And then.
So no,
I don't think the manipulation argument
is,
I don't think it's a credible one.
I mean,
I understand it and I'm an admirer of
Freud,
you know,
but I think he got wrong.
I think he walked out wrong and that was
certainly one of the places that he
disagreed most profoundly with Carla Yom
and I think only came out of it right in
Freud came out of it wrong.
Um,
and then I think the Marxist critique of
religion,
it's just like every other Marxist
critique.
It's like,
yeah,
you can treat religious religion,
religious structures is if they're
oppressive.
Power structure is only,
but you know,
it is just a reduction of a
multidimensional complexity to a,
to a relatively predictable
unidimensional dimensional in a
dimensional phenomenon.
It's not helpful.
It's not unhelpful.
Intellectual exercise passed its
immediate self evidence,
you know,
because the self evidence is some
religious people are corrupt.
So like,
yeah,
right.
Obviously
that,
that's fair.
And given the I'm taking,
I'm taking one concept heaven way out of
context of a huge bundle of things.
So that's,
yeah,
there's a writer named,
um,
I should tell you about this guy,
Jeffrey Burton,
Russell,
Russell.
You'd like him?
Yeah.
He's written a couple of books on heaven
and a very good series on the devil as a
historian.
So he's a historian of the idea of
heaven and the idea of the devil.
So we had three volume series on the
devil.
What is Mephistopheles,
which I think is the best one,
but if you're interested in,
in that kind of idea,
Jeffrey Burton,
Russell is a good person to,
to take a look at.
He's credible,
credible historian.
And I think his books are extremely
interesting,
so good.
And he delves into the idea of heaven in
a much more fundamental way than,
than the typical.
Especially the typical sort of cowardly
religious critical postmodern is to
always assume that there's nothing to it
except power dynamics.
It's foolish because having a minimum is
a vision of a better future even even as
even as only that.
It's by no means trivial.
I mean,
human beings are about the only
creatures that can imagine a better
future and so heaven is like the
architects will better future.
Yes.
So you don't want to just demolish that
idea too casually because we're always
working.
Unless we're pathological,
we're always working for a better
future.
So.
And to think of heaven is the idea that
sort of shining behind that,
the,
you know,
the implied tonic ideal of the idea of a
better future,
that's a perfectly reasonable thing to
think.
If you don't want to just throw it away
that that'd be throwing away one of the
greatest ideas of mankind.
And that doesn't mean I think the people
should be politically utopians.
It's not the same thing.
Yes,
it's the,
it's the concept that,
that has the psychological effects on
the way people behave.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
it's right.
And it's the concept that some value,
like I think the difference between the
Christian idea of having an political
utopian idea of having is that for
Christians having is what would be
achieved through the use of truth,
individual truth,
and for the political utopian would be
as a consequence of the instantiation of
some particular political system.
The same thing at all.
All right.
And then we have about 10 more minutes
by my time.
Yep.
So,
uh,
you answered those questions.
They're really good question.
Thank you.
Um,
I spent a long time thinking which to
ask because obviously there's a million
questions.
You're one that the only people I've had
faith in that could answer some of the
questions I've had.
So what do you do?
Um,
I,
I like to think of myself as a
philosopher.
Socrates.
I am a student.
I go in and out of school.
I tend to make money when I need to.
Doing our jobs in green day.
Like I don't have a lot of value on
society.
Societies.
What are your future plans?
I want to go into academia.
I want to do research.
Well,
you're pretty smart.
You know,
that's a good plan.
Those are good questions.
Um,
I,
it's school is expensive in the types of
schools that I,
I go to were kind of boring.
I like if I could go to your class every
day,
I would be the happiest person ever.
Um,
but the,
the type of teachers,
not that they're not intelligent,
they're just not a Sam Harris or Neil
degrasse Tyson or a Jordan Peterson.
I spent a lot of time reading,
reading through Einstein over and over
again,
reading through our,
listening to Neil degrasse Tyson.
I liked learning.
I just,
the university doesn't give me,
um,
substantial means of learning.
I don't feel like I learned much.
I get the picture.
It's a problem that you've got is that
there's some utility in credentials.
So you know,
there's always the possibility of going
to university for the credentials and
educating yourself at the same time what
you really have to do if you go to
university anyways.
I know it's a,
but you know,
it's always an uncomfortable meld
between what you want and what should be
and what you can get.
Yes.
Mark Twain says,
I never let my schooling interfere with
my education.
Well,
right.
Yes,
exactly.
That's perfect.
Yes.
So that's what I'm doing.
I have a couple of semesters left.
Uh,
the problem is I don't know.
I,
I have a couple of semesters left.
I go to the University of Michigan.
The problem is my motivation,
um,
which I've watched a lot of the videos
on your motivation.
I can't find the motivation to do the
work if I was at Harvard or Princeton or
Yale or somewhere where I was
challenged,
where I would be like,
this is a huge opportunity for me.
I'm going to build the judge for
yourself somehow.
Have you done the future?
The what program?
Future authoring program?
Um,
I,
I have done that.
Yes.
I think I was too focused subconsciously
with the reasons why it would help,
um,
determining why,
why this would help me.
It's helping me because of this is
helping me because of that in kind of
like playing mind games with myself,
making it so it didn't really help me as
much.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well,
because you know,
the fact is,
given,
given your level of,
let's say again to you,
you would have to have a pretty good
goal to,
to know it's not atypical for someone to
be very smart and very open,
but not very conscientious.
And I don't know if you're not very
conscientious,
maybe you are,
but what you said so far suggests that
you're higher in openness and lowering
conscientiousness.
What,
what you need to rectify that if you're,
if you can rectify it,
is this suitably lofty goal and so,
and,
but,
but if you didn't do the future
authoring program in a manner that
helped you establish that goal,
it probably isn't going to help you.
Like,
do you obviously need to reason and fair
enough,
you know.
So I guess my goal would to be going to
Grad school at an Ivy League college.
I would.
Cool.
And I'll have to.
I mean,
at one point I,
uh,
I wrote a letter to like basically
everybody that works at the Harvard
admissions,
my finding the,
uh,
the,
the emails and,
and like sent a letter explaining my
situation,
my family situation.
Why I didn't get good grades in high
school,
why I've never been on a typical good
student,
but I have a large drive and motivation
to learn and I know every single
professor at Harvard and I'm familiar
with their work.
I've read their abstracts in their,
uh,
in their journals.
Not every single one,
maybe exaggerating,
but I'm very familiar and with Yale too.
And why did they go into linguistics and
I never got a response back and I kind
of just sunk back into my,
my read and ignore the,
uh,
the universe type of thing,
but they definitely where I need to set
a goal and not sink back into my
behavior like central drift,
but actually go towards that goal.
Yep.
Well,
you know,
you have a good goal to go to Grad who
are incredible graduate school and to
pursue an academic career as a good
goal,
but you also might want to really think
hard about what the hell you're going to
do if that doesn't happen because you
know,
you're kind of built for it.
So it'd be a good pursuit.
And you know,
you sound like the kind of guy who could
use a phd so.
Well,
your questions were smart,
you know,
I had to listen to them heart and you
thought about them a lot and they were
sophisticated,
so,
um,
you know,
and that puts you in the top one percent
of students,
probably something like that,
something like that,
one to five percent.
And so you've got the right kind of mind
for it.
And with a mind like that,
you also really want to get yourself
disciplined because,
um,
it's also safer if you have a mind like
yours to get disciplined because the
problem with a mind like yours isn't,
it'll,
uh,
you'll be chasing it everywhere.
Like someone with annealed a badly
trained bloodhound.
Yeah.
And that's,
that can be really hard on a person over
time,
you know,
because it's easy to be one of those
people that has a tremendous amount of
potential but doesn't have it realized
and why that's a rough life by the time
you're about 40.
Yes.
I'm also,
what is a linguistically defined as a
polymath where academia is one interest
that I'm showing you right now because
you're an academic,
but I have a wide variety of interests
like music,
art.
Yeah.
Well that's,
that's where my thinking fitness
is high.
So I do have other opportunity,
you know,
childish Donald Glover,
he is a,
he's a rapper and I'm a standup comedian
and he's writing deadpool.
He's done.
Yes.
He's very,
very identify a lot with him looking at
him as a role model.
He does a lot of different things and he
were,
I don't know,
his,
the profanity in his work makes it
discredits his talent by a lot of
people.
But like so did,
um,
Shakespeare,
I mean basically what the things he says
is witty and punny and a pro,
a profane of course,
but so is Shakespeare,
you know,
for the time.
But I identify a lot with him.
Well,
I'm afraid I have to bring on someone
else's right up here,
but.